what's up vlog in the airport actually
heading to Sweden and actually going to
Copenhagen to connect I think we're
actually going to this is very meta
I'm going to Copenhagen I'm going to
Copenhagen to connect to Gothenburg and
then to Stockholm and this is the prelim
to a Copenhagen's keynote I gave very
recently second session you can and you
can't second session very deep after a
first session I already gave that you've
seen as you can imagine was really
challenged to to kind of like spur up
new stuff for a second session which we
did I'm fired up I hope you enjoy it
check it there's a couple things I want
to talk about while we're here and want
to make sure I'm hitting more mature
businesses around management and
structure of managing people startup
culture the framework of attention which
is I think the one thing that really
runs through this entire conference is
before you can tell anybody how good
your trampoline business is or your art
businesses or your SAS product or you as
a personal brand or we all are trading
attention and and I'm obsessed with this
it is why I believe anybody who's been
successful is able to achieve their
goals and there's a lot going on there
so I I think the thing that I want to
start with is that we've got to really
wrap our head around the framework that
we're living within as business people
this device is the remote control of our
lives this device is the remote control
of our lives and you are going to be in
a scary place with the amount of time
you actually are looking here versus
looking in the actual world you may
judge that you may think that's bad or
sad or ruining the human race it's
completely irrelevant what you think
it's what's happening and so I want to
make sure that everybody starts
backwards for you to get what you want
in your life and business you have to
give the other people the thing they
want so that you get what you want I
call it 50 140
basically every relationship I have
every business dealings I have and the
way I frame up my entire being it's why
I have popularity or cult of personality
it's because I think it's smart to give
more to an audience than you ask for it
in return and so when you're building
your product and your service and
whatever you're up to you need to find
the angle of leverage you were competing
with a lot of other people that want
people's attention when I started
working with Budweiser the beer it was
crazy to me I walked into a meeting and
I said you know okay we're competing
with Miller Carl's burger we're
competing right we're competing and they
said we're comparing for share of the
throat
Budweiser globally worries about how
much water you're drinking
how much coca-cola you're drinking I
mean it was just really interesting and
it was kind of how I think about
attention you may be thinking you're
competing against somebody else who has
a trampoline business you're not you're
competing against anybody who has
anything else to do that weekend in
Denmark with those four hours so we are
living through a world my friends where
there's more options than ever how many
people here manage how how many people
here have more than 10 employees raise
your hands right you're we're living in
a world where our employees have more
options than ever either to do things
for themselves or other employers and no
matter how good your labor laws are and
how long they have to stay with you
before they go to the knee job they
still have options greater than there
were 10 or 15 years ago so I think the
biggest thing that I think a lot about
is supply and demand it is such a simple
basic business trade and it's something
I'm very intuitive towards and it is
basically how I think about everything
how I manage my people how I create my
business how I treat my customers it is
a supply and demand world and you need
to understand that the cost of creating
things that can pull our customers
attentions away from us has gotten so
low that there is so much supply there
is so much supply of information and
videos and pictures that this is the
reason that I believe that advertising
not that it's dead
but the thought that you're gonna put
out something that is selfishly in your
interest and you're gonna get somebody
to actually pay attention to it with the
technology advances that we have today
and with all the supply of information
is almost impossible and every day that
goes by it will become more impossible
so number one first and foremost I need
people to start thinking that there are
a media company and a publisher more
than there an advertiser for their
business that this the skill set that I
think so many people will get in the
future to succeed is how do I put a
piece of content how do I make a white
paper how many people here are b2b raise
your hands
great so for you for your world how do
you make a white paper that's six pages
deep a presentation on Skillshare then
post on LinkedIn because Skillshare is
owned by LinkedIn and when you use
skills share on LinkedIn more people
organically see it tactic how do you
make a skill share that gives people
value and it's not a sales deck for
somebody to sign up for a free trial in
your landing page optimized funnel so
that you then become a client it is just
black and white an incredible piece of
information that all the construction
workers that all the lawyers that all
the CTOs in your target audience will
get value out and basically what I'm
saying very carefully to all of you is I
I when I wrote Jab Jab Jab right hook
and the Thank You economy the they were
the two titles there was a third title I
never used it was called gilt marketing
I basically believed that the place that
we're going is unless you guilt your
audience into doing business with you
because you provided so much upfront
value that you will get suffocated over
the next decade or two of opportunities
for the end consumer and so that what I
do every day is think about that and so
when I think about gilt marketing
provided value where's the underpriced
attention I used to call this slide used
to say a year ago
market in the year that you live in that
we should be marketing like it's 2016 is
what I would say market in the year that
you live in because so many of you are
spending some time and money on things
that work much better in 2012 2009 2006
so it was market in the year that you
live in what's happened is with the
speed of updates on Facebook and
Instagram and snapchat and LinkedIn
mobile devices apps VRA are podcasts all
this with the speed I've now changed it
to day trading attention because you
can't just decide what you're gonna do
in January in 2017 and have success
because too much is happening during the
year right before Instagram became the
thing that I think is the absolute kind
of like current state of the union of
social media I was making content that
said Instagram was in trouble snapchat
was exploding and getting older
Facebook was far more successful under
30 than most people realized and I made
a video you know nine months ago or so
that said what's Instagram gonna do it
copied everything that snapchat had
that's what they were gonna do and it
worked for them but it's fun for me to
know that that was day trading there's a
video out there that says instagrams in
trouble I stand here today and say
instagrams the most important so I think
the biggest thing that I want to make
sure in my keynote I get across is the
themes of the Q&A earlier which is yes
and yes and yes and audacity audacity
audacity you have to wrap your head
around the game you're playing in which
is the following there is more
information created now in 24 hours then
used to be created in decades only 50
years ago like let's just stick with me
here there is more content being created
in 24 hours then used to be created in
the decades of the 50s and 60s now do
you feel as good about your documentary
do you feel as good about your poster it
gets hard when you actually understand
what the [ __ ] is actually happening here
and so what I believe is happening for
all the business
so owners in here and entrepreneurs is
that you need to wrap your head around
the mindset of how you get yourself into
a place of accepting this and then
acting on it and how does it become
practical the reason I brought up
interns earlier is there's always supply
and demand when something emerges other
opportunity happens Amazon scaring
everybody in retail in America and other
parts of the world right Amazon is in
the wine business they bought Whole
Foods they now have liquor licenses in
every state everybody at my dad's
company Wine Library scared and me
excited why not because I'm a character
or I'm trying to act cool because I go
on Amazon site and I find wines that
Amazon has that we're selling for less
and then I send emails to customer that
say cheaper than Amazon which is true
and then from a branding standpoint it
makes them think we're incredible
because nobody's cheaper than Amazon on
anything and even though Amazon is gonna
take market share they're not gonna take
it from me in every single thing that
happens I just said more content in 24
and 48 hours than in decades ooh [ __ ]
how are people gonna watch my stuff
meanwhile more creators that are
talented than we've ever seen before
every single person here should write a
blog post send an email make a video or
make an audio piece of content tomorrow
hiring three content producers as
interns or the lowest possible cost you
can pay them based on the laws in this
country tomorrow you immediately have a
media company at remarkably low price
including if it's allowed free depending
on the rules and that's what you should
be thinking about because if you do not
wrap your head around that you were a
media company first I don't care what
you do if you do not wrap your head
around that you were a media company
first comma a lawyer comma a designer
comma a sneaker salesman if you do not
understand that you were a media [ __ ]
your business like the earlier questions
you don't have to become a personal
brand but that means your logo of your
company has to become a brand that
produces content that actually has value
to the target audience that you're
trying to set now don't take it very
direct let me give you an example I have
a lawyer friend who's starting a golf
podcast he's starting a podcast around
golf once a week he's interviewing
golfers golf in the business but he's a
lawyer looking for other people to hire
him as a lawyer his strategy is that the
people that are actively hardcore about
golf in America are high net worth
individuals who can afford the law
practice that he provides so that if he
makes something that those doctors and
other business people want to listen to
golf that because it's brought to you by
this law firm he will get the residual
business now my friends this is actually
a tactic that is hundreds of years in
the making and uniquely European let me
explain the Guinness beer company the
Guinness beer company started the
Guinness Book of World Records
because pub sales were down and they
wanted them to grow and they did
surveying and realize that people talked
about trivia in the pubs and they
decided to create the Guinness Book of
World Records so that people in the pubs
would talk about the crazy world records
reinforced the Guinness brand and then
order a pint of Guinness Michelin the
reason you've gone to a two or three
star Michelin restaurant is because
almost a hundred years ago the Michelin
tire company wanted rich people from
London and Paris to start driving to the
countryside and stop by the gas stations
and use up their tires so they bought
new ones so they started favorably
reviewing restaurants hotels and inns in
the countryside and then making a book
that drove propaganda and media
to the rich in those towns and people
started going there for the best foie
gras media as marketing for business
results what is old becomes new and that
in a framework is the new strategy that
I think has the biggest upside for every
business in here regardless of what you
do how you get people to pay attention
is the tactics that I'm most excited
about whether that is Google where that
is Facebook whether that is something
else once you establish what your media
is about and listen by the way I'm
standing up here I am very very
empathetic that where I'm going right
now for the last five to seven meaning
minutes feels like you like like if
you're running your business and I'm
sitting up here and I'm telling you that
you need to become the BBC or CBS or you
know like Skynet like I understand
however please take me up on this offer
and explore just a little bit if it
starts as simple as writing a very
thoughtful piece on your Facebook page
that you think the people that are the
people that could potentially be your
customers would get value out of not you
get value out of they get value out of
you would be flabbergasted by the
opportunities and the things that could
happen the young man over there the last
47 questions he listened to a tactic
which I believe in that everybody here
should pay attention to whether you're
trying to pick the people that you're
going to give a poster for free or
anything else the other arbitrage that
I'm massively excited about and the
tactic that I want to give you here in
the keynote is DMing people on instagram
there is a phenomenon going on that is
very intriguing you need to make a list
of the 50 to 100 people that you want to
speak to whether you want them to be the
spokesperson of your brand whether you
want them to be your first customer
whether you just think they're famous
and you want to be their friend I want
you to make a list of the hundred people
you
Nordics in Europe in the world that you
would like to have a relationship with
for a business reason I want you to then
search their profile on Instagram if you
do not find it go to google and type in
the person's name and the word Instagram
after their last name so it shows up I'm
being very tactical here very mundane
but I believe attention arbitrage is
also a way for where is the best
business development opportunity for
everybody in the room the best business
development opportunity in this room is
to not do what many people do which is
spam people on LinkedIn because nobody's
paying attention anymore it is to go to
Instagram find their Instagram some of
the people you want will not be on there
that's fine but the ones the eighty
three of the hundred the forty seven of
the hundreds that are you DM them direct
message if you are not native to
Instagram or don't understand that
there's a thing you can do you go to
Google and you search how do i direct
message people on Instagram it will take
you four minutes and listen this is like
a fun thing to do because you have to
understand this is what people ask we
were like be more tactical on key no
great here you go this is what it is
it's that basic that's why but this is
super important because you were blown
away by what happened when you started
doing it right I'm blown away by what
has happening on DM I became friends
with the rock and you know and all sorts
of characters that I never thought I
would ever interact with because
people's attention is on their direct
message now most of you will make the
mistake that you will go in for the ask
on your first writings you will DM and
you'll say hey Rach can you wear my
t-shirt of my brand no [ __ ] he will
not do that but if you look at their
last three or four posts if you spend
ten minutes don't forget you're only
going after a hundred people this is the
business that you want to build and see
what they're about and you look and you
say hey Rach I see you have a movie
coming out that you're excited about I
want to make some free posters for you
you know or whatever it may be if you
bring value in your first exchange on DM
you will be stunned and I get this email
30 times a day every day just read three
of them before I got back on Sage of
people who made the biggest business
development deals of their lives on
Instagram direct message in the last 30
days singularly for the same reason that
email worked so well in nineteen ninety
seven eight nine ten because how many
people here had email in 1999 perfect do
you remember what we did in ninety nine
with email we read every [ __ ] email
we do not do that anymore supply and
demand of attention something emerges we
pay attention that a marketer and
marketers and business people come along
they ruin it and then we move on that is
why I talk about day trading of
attention that no matter if you have no
money or you have a huge business you
know I love when people like if we get
to Q&A and like Gary this is all great
Facebook and Instagram great but my
company does 38 million dollars and we
grew 13% this year and we only do direct
mail and conferences what do you say
about that
what I say about that Hans is what's
wrong with growing 74 percent [ __ ]
this is not about what works or doesn't
work this is about where is the upside
to create even more success of whatever
you want to raise money for a charity
this is not about this doesn't work this
does work this is about the tactics and
the strategy that is needed to maximize
the opportunity cuz here's the part that
I have not told you when I get
introduced and they say Gary built his
dad's business from three to sixty
million dollars in five years and some
people like you know a lot of people
don't know who I mean that sounds good
you know better than just some guy
yelling and cursing on stage I sit in
the side and I say
it should have been 200 and it should
have been 200 because I was not day
trading attention in 1998 I was but I
wasn't great at it yet
I had Google I had Google the first day
Google AdWords came out I bought every
wine term they were 5 cents a click and
I was converting customers for 47 cents
who were worth [ __ ] $30 for me what I
didn't understand because I was a kid it
was it just I didn't know the difference
is that I should have poured all my
money into Google not print and radio
and television and newspaper which is
what I did I spent much more on Google
than anybody else but nobody even knew
what it was but if I took all that money
and all that energy and I struck when it
was that good of a deal I would have had
a much bigger business and more success
and if you were here to have success in
whatever you're trying to communicate
you need to understand that social media
which is a word that we made up so let
me say the different way that the
current state of the internet attention
is on Facebook and Instagram and
LinkedIn and that the opportunity to
strike and maximize dollar amounts out
of it is so extraordinary and they're
the only thing I want to say other than
that is if you do it you will be like
some of the kids that raised her hand
right now and said this good thing
happened and if you're not you're gonna
raise your hand when I'm in Copenhagen
in seven years talking about voice and
they are and you're gonna say Gary I'm
listening to you because you were here
seven years ago and you told me to do
this and I didn't and I watched other
people do it and I didn't grow as much
or I lost or I missed my opportunity and
now I'm listening to you this time I am
saying this to put a flag in the ground
to be historically correct Facebook
advertising is grossly underpriced and
everybody here should move as much of
their money into the platform as they
possibly can because and like these two
chicks are high-fiving so I don't know
what is going on over there but I can't
wait to find out
but I promise you they're not
high-fiving because they've run Facebook
ads and it didn't work and more
importantly watch this this is important
how many of you have run Facebook ads
and it has not worked raise your hands
should be plenty raise your hands raise
em high don't be higher raise them hi hi
hi hi
it's important thank you running
Facebook ads and it not being successful
just so there's no confusion is not a
Facebook issue it's a u issue you did
not plan the media properly you did not
make the words and pictures work
properly but this is not a debate this
is data supported and I don't want to
hear that your customers aren't on it
because that doesn't exist
it just doesn't and I don't want to hear
that your industry doesn't do well on it
cuz it doesn't exist
it just doesn't we've sold jet engines
on Facebook and I'm very tired of going
to meetings over the last six months
we're 70 year old executives say to me
for the first 30 minutes of our dinner
can you believe this Facebook they need
to regulate it it changed the election
the [ __ ] Russians and Trump and the
brexit and the [ __ ] and our
grandchildren and this and all that and
then we segue into their business and I
start telling them they need to spend
more money on Facebook and they go well
there's no ROI there or my customers not
there so I'm making a very passionate
play because I want you to win for you
to become a practitioner do you know
many people here have opinions on
Facebook marketing but have never run an
ad you've read an article in The Wall
Street Journal Congrats you're a talking
head you're not a practitioner you have
an opinion off of two conversations with
somebody you trust but you're not a
practitioner you have an intuition but
you're not a practitioner so if nothing
else go spend $3,000 on Facebook with
your money you do it I don't need you to
outsource 26 year old Karen
it's not a kids thing this is the most
important place where the attention of
our end consumer is at scale and let me
tell you one great thing you have
because it is so underestimated in the
Nordics by the media companies it's
under priced because it's a market place
but the behavior of the users in the
region are extraordinary in depth of
attention scroll time is slower which
means there's more consumption age is
wider it goes younger here and a little
bit older and the companies are not
spending your big companies in this
countries are not spending enough money
in it so the prices are down how many
people bought Google AdWords in 2002 3/4
raise your hands for all the
practitioners here there's not a one
more time but Google AdWords 2003 4
right for some of us here go look I
don't know if you're still doing it go
look back at right now tonight what
those words costs compared to 2000 2 3 4
this is the moment strike on it and if
you don't understand it don't outsource
to an agency don't outsource to your 21
year old friend start googling on how I
make Facebook ads how I create it for it
what works start testing and start using
different variables next how many people
have 25 or more employees raise your
hands just try to get a sense so I want
to talk about employees for a minute
culture this is managing yourself three
person team 10:25 I'm a very big
believer in starting to follow employees
on social media and getting a better
sense of who they are I spend probably
90% of my media consumption just reading
comments of the content I put out and
the people in my community that read it
and then I click their face and go in a
rabbit hole and find out about them we
are spending not enough time listening
to our employees our vendors and our
customers but the place where you get
the disproportionate highest ROI is when
you listen to your employees retention
on the employee level is imperative
happiness is imperative because it leads
to speed and speed is the competitive
advantage that you have against your
competitors in your product and service
and when nobody's worried about politics
or drama they can worry about the work
and so I don't want to spend too much
time on it based on the hands but if you
were managing people and you've not had
a sit-down with one of your employees in
the last six months or a year to find
out what they care about today whether
that's money work life balance
title fame and more importantly if you
have an employee that is actually
seriously important to your business
which oh by the way means if you have
one employee and they're the only
employee have and it's you and them and
you do not have an understanding of what
drives them you need to have a two and a
half hour dinner and create that glue
because one of the biggest things I see
in businesses and entrepreneurs and
failing is the over reliance on an
employee that leaves and then they have
to start all over for 18 months or are
completely crippled by it and the thing
that could have allowed them to mitigate
that disaster is literally a
conversation and if you're not a big
enough man or woman to hear the feedback
well your company's gonna lose anyway so
not having the conversation doesn't
address the issues that are happening
within your company so I implore all of
you to start getting very serious about
this because if we're having a business
talk the part about business that we
don't talk enough about is empathy for
our customers but most importantly for
our employees none of your employees I
love when people like Gary encompassing
Gary how do I get my employees to work
as hard as me you don't Frederick
no employees should ever work as hard as
you unless they have the same equity in
the company as you the audacity that
employed my dad would pay people $12 an
hour and want them to work as hard as he
did I would always make me laugh I know
it's very Russian and I get it
cultural fine but it was super
interesting to me I'm like that they're
making $12 an hour you own the business
it's hard for them to care and so I
really really really want to push
empathy for the humans that you're doing
business with because it's how you
become the best salesperson it's how you
become the best manager it's a default
of thinking about the other person not
yourself tactics one more time it seemed
like a lot one more time I apologize but
give it to me
b2b businesses raise your hands let's
talk about LinkedIn for a little bit
LinkedIn's add product sucks and it's
unfortunate because it could be so great
and it could be so great
if they just literally copied Facebook
like if everybody here could run ads
with creative against the titles of
people's jobs you would have the
greatest tool of all time because most
of you and b2b are selling to people
that hold one of four to five titles it
would be remarkable it's not there yet
it's got a high floor it's not a low
floor like Facebook and Google but I'm
seeing things that are making me
ambitious that the promise that they
were gonna be better three four years
ago is finally maybe coming here I think
Microsoft sees it I think it's coming
which is why if you follow me carefully
I've been doubling and tripling down on
my LinkedIn content myself because I'm
trying to understand it better so I
could give better advice to GE and s AP
and the clients we work with and so I
highly recommend that if you're a b2b
player they start allocating real
dollars to LinkedIn even though there is
a way to target people on Facebook
let me paint you a very tactical thing
b2b I want you to run two different
tests LinkedIn but let me give you a
very detailed ad product on Facebook
that I think is enormous ly
why positive on Facebook how many people
here have spent over $50,000 in facebook
ads with them doing it not outsourcing
it through an agency raise your hand
okay three okay so that's fine
it's what I thought and what I actually
hoped and that's a big number
Facebook if you're not a practitioner
you don't know what the capabilities are
right you know if you've never opened
the Swiss Army knife you don't know
what's in it right there is a
segmentation in facebook called
employees of everybody here and b2b can
run pictures videos or words against
people that are employees of specific
companies in their Facebook feed if you
understand how powerful this is and what
you can do next
you'll start unlocking some incredible
business opportunities by targeting the
employees of and now you know that your
product is sold to the CIO or the CTO or
the CFO or the director of logistics now
your copy or the video you make starts
with does your CFO know does your
product managers understand want to save
time for your accountants if you
literally verbatim articulate in written
or video form or picture form the does
the person in your company that is this
know about this and then you follow it
with information a compelling video a
how-to what have you we have seen
ungodly amounts of the following you run
a thousand dollars in ads against five
companies and anywhere between three and
seventy four employees of that company
forward that post to the decision maker
and it is so extreme and unusual that if
the creative is good and you jab instead
of right hook that it has been one of
the greatest conversion rate
advertising's we've seen in any shape or
form over the last half decade and it is
a b2b facebook ad strategy so
I can't wait for two months from now to
get an email from one of you that
actually ran this and felt the results
so please take that and run with it look
I think that we should talk about voice
because I think that is something that a
lot of you are gonna have to wrap your
head around going to the next 24 to 36
months and this may be a place where
some of you have the personalities where
it feels overwhelming to catch up to
everybody on this social stuff but the
excitement of being first on the next
thing is just your personality trait and
you'd like to invest and that feels more
exciting because you don't feel dumb and
you feel smart I don't know what your
insecurities are but I promise you here
is a very important thing to talk about
voice besides money health and religion
time is the fourth pillar of the things
that drive us all of you do so many
things like give up privacy to save a
little time every day of your lives it's
how we roll
uber sold time not transportation many
of the things you choose every day are
you buying time back and you're willing
to pay the margin for the convenience I
believe that audio in our society is the
next frontier because it is selling back
time how many people here consume my
content raise your hands raise them high
I want everybody look around because I'm
about to show you something pretty
interesting of those people how many of
you have started listening more to my
podcasts in the last year and watching
less sub videos raise your hand this is
remarkable like this is rook thank you
this is remarkable I would say that's 30
to 50 percent that same question just a
year earlier would have been
non-existent what is happening is
podcaster grow how many people here are
actively listening to a podcast raise
your hands
it's incredible how many of you were not
doing that just three years ago
raise your hands yeah this is [ __ ] it
and this is day-trading attention you've
got to watch these trends sound audio
it's saving us time while you're
commuting while you're doing something
else you're able to consume
content and because we underestimate the
brand the brain and our ability to
multitask you're able to do something
else as well and are you completely
holding everything no but you start you
know it's the reason do you know many
people should be dying based on how many
people text while they drive this is an
interesting thought I'm glad you guys
reacted the amount of people that should
be dying because of texting and driving
is enormous it's still higher than we'd
like to admit but the reason it's not
happening is we can do more things than
people realize at the same time and that
is what sound is doing for us podcasts
but the one that's gonna save us way
more time is what's coming up with
alexis skills and briefings on top of
the amazon alexa the one that's coming
from google home the Apple home pod and
whoever else decides to enter whether
it's Samsung or Facebook or somebody
else because when you get into a place
where you're brushing your teeth and you
say hey Alexa reorder my toothpaste and
it's done you're living in a totally
different world what do you guys do when
you're running around your life and you
remember that you've got to do something
you take out your phone most likely and
you do something that will normally take
you somewhere between 14 seconds to text
somebody to two minutes to write a note
or call somebody I don't know how you
roll but I can tell you that time is the
thing that all of you will trade on and
the biggest white space to change your
business in the next 24 to 36 months is
gonna be about your investment to
understand how your product and service
can penetrate the time Gorem aka if in
2007 8 9 you decided to be good at
Facebook and LinkedIn and Twitter you
would have some of the things that
happen to me because I went all in you
need to figure out the same thing for
time because these skills and briefings
for example mark my words 5 6 years from
now everybody will wake up and they will
treat one of these devices like the
morning radio remember some of you woke
up with the morning radio alarm it would
go off and your favorite morning show
radio show would start talking your news
and weather and then do that this is
what your device is gonna do you're
gonna all download apps skills to your
voice device and your first seven
minutes of the morning are gonna be
curated with your bank account balance
with the weather with your favorite
sports teams update with the six most
important things in your business with
your schedule you will listen passively
now you grab your phone go to the
bathroom take a poop and look at your
phone in the future you will wake up and
the first seven minutes will start
talking to you about things and you'll
start interacting with it
Alexa changed that meeting canceled that
tell Tyler I want to go to Copenhagen
three hours earlier it will be you and
the Machine and I highly recommend that
you start getting serious about it don't
believe it let me show you some consumer
behaviors that you would find
interesting how many people here by
remember lying is the devil how many of
you here by show of hands now get
annoyed when another human being
calls you raise your hand stand up do me
a favor get up I mean it I want
everybody see how dramatic this is I see
some of you didn't do it yet thank you
up there look around look up and down
I'm gonna give you two more set keep
staying up please keep staying up keep
staying up I want everybody to see this
I'm gonna give you another so I'm gonna
ask it one more time in case you didn't
hear it you were now upset annoy like
why would that person call me they can
text me or email me
you were genuine you react poorly to
another human being calling you look at
this this is something that was the most
standard way we communicated 36 48
months ago thank you more than half this
room is upset literally come on mom [ __ ]
you you know
text me I'll call you on my time listen
[Music]
do you know many people here because
this is not just eighteen year olds
didn't think they were gonna get a cell
phone because their pager was good
enough I remember those days
do you know how many people here were
not gonna text cuz texting was for kids
do you know how many people here thirty
six months ago when they saw emojis for
the first time thought it was the
stupidest [ __ ] of all time but last
night sent a poop emoji we see new forms
of communication and we resist them
until we realize they save us time that
thumbs up emoji has saved me a lot of
time because it's quicker for me to say
good instead of okay kay it's just speed
and if you're not paying attention we
are going so hyper and that is well
sound voice is the next frontier if you
can figure out how to build an Alexis
skill that helps people with your
product and service that is a gateway
drug then to your overall product and
service you know how some of you have
tried to come up with free ebooks free
trials free this free that gateways into
you if you are able to provide that in
sound invoice if you then figure out how
when you have to understand what happens
how many people anybody here build an
iPhone app when the app store first came
out okay what happened was there was a
land grab there was not a lot of apps we
all had the phone and so we went in
there and there was not as many apps and
we picked the apps that we wanted there
was a land grab there will be an land
grab how many people here have been the
in the Alexa the Amazon Alexis skill
store how many of you have been in there
raise your hands right about seven eight
nine of you right so you've seen right
it's interesting there's stuff there but
not a lot of stuff right this is the
white space that I recommend for the
people here that are really trying to
leapfrog who are willing to like the
first question each [ __ ] for 24 to 36
months stay around stay around
stay around and then let the market come
to you two thousand nine ten eleven
twelve of vaynermedia no company wanted
social media what's the ROI what is it
it's stupid aren't talking about us on
Twitter we don't want people talking
about us don't litter and play did they
did it but we stayed around we stayed
around and if you're a stay around
player if you're young if you've got the
dollars to invest and you're worried
about being at the mercy of Google or
other things and you want to diversify
or if you just generally believe what I
believe which is that technology is
eating up our society and technology is
not a thing it is oxygen well then you
will get very serious about the last ten
minutes of my rant here about voice and
you will go to google and you will
search how to build an Alexa skill
what's the difference between an Alexa
skill and Alexa briefing I'll give it to
you quickly a briefing is dumb you just
record something in it plays a skill is
AI and technology and you can interact
with it
it's more of an app and so I think this
is a huge space it's the one I'm most
excited about I have not invested in
startups for the last 15 to 24 months
because I hate them all I think
everything is overpriced
I think everybody's an entrepreneur I
don't think anybody's interesting
anymore I think it's all Club promoters
that now think they're entrepreneurs it
just sucks but this is the first time I
feel ready to invest again because I
went to Seattle
I saw the incubator that is only people
building on top of Alexa it's creative
[ __ ] I never thought of I saw an app
that you say Alexa I'm starting to read
the book you read a child's book you
start talking the boy ran through the
street and Alexis starts making it sound
of a boy running in the street and as
you're reading Alexa is complimenting
you with surround sound he jumped in the
puddle it started to rain I said you
know it's funny I don't think you can
zoom in but maybe you two can see it my
goosebumps i sat there and I said oh my
god no child will be read a book in
seven years without background noise
complementing the content right you
understand
it's just so interesting there's just so
much and let me tell you when your
shirts collar is sound activated and use
when Alexis starts making deals with
Ralph Lauren and your collar is there
and anything you think that you need to
create lack of friction up you just say
and it gets done we will all be addicted
to that because that is speed and if you
could be the Alexa I need a lawyer
all of a sudden Google search is in
trouble
and so we live in a world where we've
accepted the reality without
anticipating what's coming next
some of us lived in a world where Yahoo
was the biggest search engine
some of us lived in the world where
Microsoft was the company that we had to
regulate because they were too big we
forget that this is always gonna keep
happening and the only thing that you
should be religious to and it went away
is the attention of the end consumer
and what's overpriced and underpriced
what's too early VR in my opinion is too
early because you've got to stay alive
for quite a long time before people do
it at scale maybe I'm right maybe I'm
wrong we'll see but we have an
incredible incredible decade ahead of us
I want to remind everybody here actually
how many people are retiring in twelve
years and I don't mean you're gonna come
up with some big idea crush it and buy
an island I mean you're [ __ ] old and
you're finished
12 years raise your hands okay
there's not six seven of us I want to
remind everybody else that twelve years
ago almost everything we talked about
did not exist not Ober not Facebook not
YouTube not the iPhone nothing and so I
implore everybody to understand what I'm
trying to do in this talk which is
change your mental strategy of what
you're gonna need to be successful this
is not about running a simple Facebook
ad this is not about learning what an
under priced or over
influencer is this is all those things
but unless you have the mindset of
patience and empathy and really
understanding the reality of the
marketplace there are people here my
friends there are multi-billion dollar
international companies that will be out
of business in five years because of
what's going on do you think you're
eight million dollar your business is
safe the level of audacity of the
entrepreneurs and business people in
here who have a 50 million dollar
business and think they're good because
they've been good for the last 15 years
is extraordinary and it is going to
create a ton of carnage in the
entrepreneurial and business landscape
because the skill sets that it will take
to survive this next 15 years are going
to be extraordinary
do you know me of your friends are out
of a job once people understand the
power of AI and machine learning I mean
do you understand the ramifications if
blockchain ever actually hit full scale
it arbitrage is out the need for
countries outside of weapons we are
living through [ __ ] crazy times and
people think it's like some silly update
like the iPhone 10 this is not this
silly [ __ ] this is the most macro thing
that has happened to human beings in
just 20 years of consumer internet we
have watched the internet tumble
dictatorships create new dynamics and
the most powerful companies excuse me
countries in the world take down the
biggest companies in the world Amazon
has become the biggest company in the
world or the potential biggest company
in the world by using Google Ads
the first seven years of Google ads
that's who the biggest advertiser was on
Google ads attention arbitrage where is
your customer what do they they do and
why are you holding up what got you here
instead of figuring out what you need to
do to still be around the great mental
flaw of this room is that you put on a
pedestal if you're successful what got
you here without realizing that is
exactly what gives you no chance to be
successful going forward for all the
accolades and all the cool things going
on with me
nothing matters that I've done yesterday
and behind is always having the level of
humility to know the customers right and
to be religious about what the customers
doing and then providing value to the
customer nothing else ever ever ever
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that was a good one Gary two years ago
at elevate the the main speaker he was
talking about how only 5% at max leaves
a room like this leaves a conference
like this and really deploys any of the
knowledge that has been that was a very
optimistic thank you
so I guess I'm insane if I have a vision
that that number should be much higher
nonetheless it's not gonna be it's it's
not and I'm not trying to cut you up
it's because what I'm trying to do right
now is make the number be two people to
three people because they're gonna get
mad that I'm calling them out and I'm
trying everything love hate oil vinegar
honey
I'm trying everything on you to do
something about this but unfortunately
it is people run their lives on defense
and fear good and and to me I hope that
you bring this up me doing that him
doing that the stakes are very high and
I think the reason we got tricked was
the world didn't change for 70 years
my friends the growth from the 30s to
2000 were minor when you understand what
the Internet's done they were big stuff
happened but there's nothing like this
[Music]
but I guess you agree then when somebody
actually does do it then it's also fair
to celebrate it yes and instead of just
asking for to put it the name on the
t-shirt but when somebody has actually
done it then it's also fair enough to do
something about it so um this guy that
we see here okay his mess and mess I
don't know if you can say that he's the
Danish version of you okay in terms of
getting views he's pretty good
yes and in terms of building a personal
brand he's done pretty well for himself
so we really would like to celebrate
when people do something so among all
the people who have asked to get some
time with you and get some time in front
of everyone here I think that mass is a
worthy candidate it's awesome so we're
math mass actually has the first
question for you here in this following
up QA but if I know him right this is
gonna turn into a little bit of a weird
thing I hope he keeps his clothes on
because half of the times when he speaks
in public half of it goes off but mass
Meyers
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello Gary how are you my friend like to
be myself when I talk to you so if you
don't mind it everyone else would like
to drop my shirt yes and I know this
might seem odd but as a 16 year old kid
I wanted to be a speaker I wanted to go
to schools and help people build their
own self-esteem I really care about the
youth and as someone who suffered from
feeling different because I had this
huge [ __ ] scar on my stomach you can
see [ __ ] but it's okay but it's 24
centimeters and if you imagine an iPad
in a vertical way that's the length of
my scar which is a lot from a small boy
so I learned to dig into the topic that
you really dig which is self-awareness
and I learned a lot about myself until I
was capable of standing at a stage and
talking to people and when I finally got
that thing going well you know I got
this [ __ ] I started to tell myself if I
cannot walk the talk social media wise
and preach my message just like I do
nowadays
then I'm [ __ ] so I did and everything
escalated and my brand started growing
and going from I live in a basement
which is quite nice but going from the
basement to becoming a national speaker
it's cause for something different and
the pressure grew within the last five
months which I love because I got a lot
of speaking jobs so that's nice I
usually say I'm a stripper which it's
because I dropped my clothes not that
the principal's office like hello but
you don't but the point is as the
pressure crew how do you as an
international speaker with all of your
attention how do you cope with all of
the pressure in terms of hate and
everything that goes on quite easily
from a very basic thing I know what my
intent is and I'm very grounded in it
and I deploy enormous amounts of empathy
to my haters when somebody leaves a
comment on
my facebook or anywhere else that I'm a
charlatan or a snake oil salesman or my
daddy gave me the money to build the
liquor store and I shouldn't be listened
to I understand why they say that I know
it's not true and and you know it feeds
me in a very good way and so for me to
be very honest with you brother it's
been very easy because when your intent
is pure and comes from complete I think
about succeeding in one very simple
story there are two ways my friends to
build the biggest building in town step
number one just build the biggest
building in town step number two build a
decent sized building and then spend all
your time trying to tear down everybody
else's building around you down so you
end up being the biggest building in
town my friend 95% of people try to do
number two but when you know you can
build the [ __ ] biggest building in
town you do that and so because I know
what my intent is I just don't value
anybody's opinion about me including my
parents and wife and children more than
I value my opinion about myself
[Applause]
boylee not directly leave I'd like to
give you something Gary this is not why
this is something that has great
importance to me because everything I've
done in the last two years building my
brand has been built upon something
different and those I give this to it's
only to those who inspired me for
example you to create this content in
this way being me
so I'd like to give you something
fantastic to give you a rubber duck and
this might seem odd but whenever I talk
I talk about becoming the ugly duckling
standing up to yourself giving zero
[ __ ] about everyone else that's where I
preach to the youth at least that's why
I'm naked
well [ __ ] if I had a six-pack I'd be
naked all the time I'd like to give you
this very cool cool now we officially
gone into the Q&A yes all right we have
the next question from math so that's
what that was miss that was well next
one fine line one back one back one back
there we go well what yep good women in
technology right who's that
yeah Lena oh she's right here could we
have a mic mother yep yes coming thank
you I'm on the way by the way this
lovely lady who just brought the mic is
wearing vans sneakers if you do what I
do for a living and try to understand
culture and how things happen vans
30 months ago got very aggressive in
paying Instagram influencers to wear
vans and that is why vans is back period
end of story
everything else is secondary that is why
so many kids are wearing bands for all
the people that are wondering why they
see more van
today period end of story hmm just
trying to help just trying to make you
see that it's happening this is not
coming I'm sorry good first of all thank
you Gary for coming I'm a big big fan
and I've been listening to your podcast
for more than a year now of yours and
ours thank you yes which makes it a
little difficult actually to ask
questions because you know all the
answers I know the answers but before I
ask them the question I just wanted to
thank you to say thank you to Casper for
actually taking the risk bringing you
here for all of us in Copenhagen small
country so I think we should actually
clap it up for Casper
[Music]
and actually that is along the lines of
the question I've I've formulated up
there is because I think Casper must
have suffocated some excuses to do what
he's done
yes and I'm working on on all my excuses
but and I see you working on people's
excuses a lot so not me Gary Vee how can
I sort of inspire people to around me to
work on their excuses by do you know
it's funny
hi long before I was Gary being this is
what I was doing for my high school
friends who were doing stupid things
like drugs and alcohol or driving drunk
because they wanted to act cool in front
of somebody this is just about self
esteem it's so simple it's almost overly
emotional for me this is about self
esteem the way I choose to do it and you
know this is how I do it as I go
directly at it if you you can every one
of us can think of somebody we care
about right now that's just not doing it
right and all you have to do is sit them
down and tell them they're not doing it
right but we don't want to do that
because we'd rather not short-term hurt
their feelings and let them fail
long-term which is remarkably crazy if
you give a [ __ ] about somebody so what
can you do is not Gary bean
have the actual conversation and tell
your sister your mom your uncle your
aunt your child your best friend the
next time they come up with an excuse
that it's a [ __ ] excuse the reason I
say the thing that if there's anybody
that ever looked like you that made it
then there's no excuse is because I
believe it you know it's really hard
here in our argument and that your
friend tells you that's great Gary but
both my parents were alcoholics and that
really [ __ ] me up right now you're on
the defense that's a good first punch by
them I'm like cool we don't need to use
me if anybody has ever been successful
that had two alcoholic parents which by
the way I know of three well then now
what's your Excuse Karen we are just so
interested in blaming everybody out
and excuses because we don't want to
take on responsibility and somewhere a
long time ago I went completely I only
take I do you know I think everything is
my fault like all of it like I think
it's weirdly cloudy outside right now
and not nice out my fault
like his scar my fault like I [ __ ]
just default into my fault and everybody
tries to do everything else the other
way and let me tell you how good life
becomes when you take on responsibility
it gets real good uh some of you and
there's a lot of PETA follow me you know
why I keep bringing up the last scene of
eight mile the M&M movie how many people
have seen that movie great the last
scene they go into the battle he makes
fun of himself the whole time because it
leaves the other person with nothing the
leverage is in being accountable of
everything the leverage is exposing your
weaknesses I proudly talk about passing
on uber twice being a DNF student you
know I proudly talk about my
shortcomings right I can't wait for more
bad things to happen I mean it because I
will talk about them because what you're
so [ __ ] perfect [ __ ] you right so how
do you do it you have the conversation
and you realize that you're doing a
disservice to the people you love the
most by holding your mouth shut because
you're not willing to deal with the
short-term conflict
[Music]
stoian where are you store him are you
here okay then I will live then we will
take the next one okay yeah what that's
a good question what is it dude do you
have a mentor yourself or a mastermind
group of people you meet on a regular
basis and discuss business matters wit
nope and how's that for a good question
yeah and this is interesting I'm trying
to figure out if I can bring you value
in this nor have I ever my mentor is you
it is far better for you to look up to
the 31 people that leave comments on
your [ __ ] than to watch me more my
mentor is the market my mentor is your
attentions and your behaviors so I'm
outside of my parents I've never put it
I don't know anything about any business
person ever I've read five books in my
life I'm not part of any group I consume
no content I I consume the market which
is why I see these things because I
watch what you do you know how Wikipedia
and YouTube you start watching something
or reading something in three hours
later you're learning about like redhead
and Eskimos right that's what I do with
people I get a lot of comments now 70%
of it is I'm the greatest [ __ ] thing
of all time which feels nice 10% of is
I'm a piece of [ __ ] and then the 20%
there's people trying to leave something
thoughtful love that 20% five percent of
it is thoughtful they've figured it out
they got it and then I click their face
who else do they follow oh they're
getting tricked by that one but they got
this why oh why are they taking pictures
of you know music festivals why are they
drinking beer wise craft beer moving
what did it and seven hours later I have
a pulse on something that's happening in
the ecosystem I didn't invest in
Facebook Twitter Tumblr
by accident I'm not hanging out with the
hip hop stars that are the next Kanye
and Drake by accident I'm doing real
hardcore research of the thing that
matters you're my mentor
[Applause]
[Music]
leading that's you again amazing listen
you're super [ __ ] talented yeah own
it how do you bring a planaria like I
can read it how do you bring or plan on
bringing your own children
it's perspective meaning yes and I guess
in Denmark we're sort of old very
privileged and you talk about your own
children almost having sort of a you
know chip on their shoulder coming now
with with you in the yeah because the
level of disrespect I have for them is
extraordinary
yeah no really I mean like like you know
when you know that's a natural reaction
the people that are handed a lot of
stuff it could it can go one of two ways
so yep how do I give them bring them the
perspective the gratitude sure eight ten
and twelve oh sorry this is the great
challenge for so many of us so first of
all there's something that I've watched
this is something I've been passionate
about long before I had them now it
really [ __ ] matters and it will
matter
you heard me earlier say forget about
what I'm doing how big come out is going
to be my legacy so I care first of all
for everybody in here you need to wrap
yourself around something most parents
don't want to wrap their head around
which is you can't fake environment the
amount of rich friends I have who send
their kid for four days to Africa to
build a school and think now they're
grounded is [ __ ] ludicrous
you can't fake environment if you are
privileged you are privileged if you are
not you are not the great gift and curse
for all of us is we had too much where
we had too little then your DNA and
parenting an environment takeover on
which path you decide what I'm doing is
there's a couple things that are my
religious Ten Commandments and I'm
sticking to those
everything else I'm unemotional about so
number one kindness kindness is
non-debatable if Xander and Misha ever
deploy mean miss on somebody else
especially based on how much money Mommy
and Daddy made I will physically punch
them in the face that's number one
kindness is not debatable number two
they have to really love what they're
into I have no interest in my kids being
an entrepreneur I have no interest in my
kids being a showman I want them to be
what the thing they love the most is
number three there's no such thing at
this fourth place trophies all these
privileged kids are being protected from
hurt feelings by parents today which is
why they're gonna suck because in real
life you come in fourth place and eighth
place so in my Upper East Side of
Manhattan culture there's a lot of 8th
place trophies and everybody's [ __ ]
great at everything I tell little kids
that are 6 you suck
their parents get mad at me but I'm like
Ricky sucks at golf
so no make-believe and then number four
almost everything else does not matter
number five
update the list as soon as I feel like I
have to in real time as soon as I see
something that makes me have to update
the list
[Applause]
[Music]
KeSPA can we get a micro no to casbah
you look surprised yeah
so what personal skill and not a
business skill do you believe to be the
most crucial for anyone to develop in
order to catapult one's business to the
next level empathy I can't let it go I
can't let it go I need you to have it I
don't know how to develop it don't go
buy [ __ ] courses to teach it you
know before you do it be thoughtful but
if you have empathy you have everything
it's just so big it's so big it makes
you incredible at sales I'm a great
all-time salesman because I'm empathetic
I basically can't even live my life
without I watched my mother and I she
has a too but we have different
obviously were different she's the
center piece of every single person that
knows her her empathy for everybody
becomes the leverage of everybody
meeting her and she took in away and I
got the benefit of watching it that I
think allowed me to find a little bit of
a better lines in the sand where to stop
and start and I'm different in a lot of
ways business see and competitive and
we're different but when you have
empathy you of everything and I just you
know there's a lot of things I care
about right gratitude it surely makes
you positive if you have perspective on
that but if I had to pick one in the way
you're asking
it's empathy man if you just like all of
you care about you not your customers
not your employees not your vendors and
I get it you have to take care of your
family I get it but it's the way if you
care about them more and figure out
what's left for you and what to do with
it you will have for the rest of your
life and I'm sure it's very biblical and
very faith driven and very altruistic it
doesn't make it any less true empathy
[Music]
yes and there we have gotten some notes
while you were speaking Lillie Dunn can
Duta yeah can we get a mic wanna - all
the way back hmm
yep hello Gary
how are you I'm good thanks you great I
have a question about passive income and
okay you know what kind of trends do you
see for a person interesting in that I
don't want to be stuck in office
nine-to-five for the rest of my well
passive income comes in two forms 97% of
the form is the douchiest shittiest
thing on earth and 3% is the
tried-and-true thing that has actually
created passive income in the history of
mankind so let's find out which side
you're on how are you thinking about
when you say passive income do you mean
some what do you mean I mean not having
to work all day long
I want to being out on a beach in Mexico
instead of being on an office in Sweden
and a cold November are you being
serious right now
yes yes I'm suppose
the quickest way to not be on a beach in
Mexico is to think the passive income
exists it's a it's a bad mindset I
really believe that I think the reason
so many scum buckets are making so much
money is because you're buying stupid
[ __ ] courses over and over thinking
there's some [ __ ] magic formula for
passive income passive income looks like
this you take money that you can afford
to go to zero and you put them in the
two places that have historically create
a passive income public markets that you
don't care if it goes up and down and
you just wait to the end or real estate
and you hope that your real estate area
doesn't get crushed everything else
almost doesn't exist I'm thinking more
of real estate because I've been
involved in it in Sweden loved it and
for all the Danish people it's pretty
like the government is very restricting
on creating a real estate business it's
a lot of taxes it's really hard if you
don't have the money in the beginning
shouldn't you work your face off to get
money not buy dumb [ __ ] like a watch and
then put it into the real estate yes I
should okay look look you know and I
think you know and I'm happy I could see
your energy I'm so passionate about this
issue there are people that are ripping
people off at the level of hundreds of
millions of dollars because they're
selling this dream because they made a
video with pretty girls in a beach in
the background and are making people
spend a thousand two thousand it's it's
breaking my heart
passive income doesn't exist and
anything that starts with I don't want
to work is already a problem what you
need to do is I understand I don't want
to work in an office or something I'm
not passionate about what I the best way
to make money is to make less money than
you're making now enough to still live
because you got to live around something
that does interest you because you wake
up eight years later and it's something
good is actually happening so it's not
the everybody wants to make it the
extreme of I'm sitting in my job I hate
it this sucks all the way to beach in
Mexico but there's a real in-between
which is why I wrote crush it which is
at night when you're done with your [ __ ]
job that is paying for the life that you
have to live right now eh you don't take
some of that money and buy dumb [ __ ]
like 17 beers watching the World Cup
what you do instead is you work on
something on the internet that cost you
nothing to start save all those dollars
build something for yourself over seven
years and then transition from the [ __ ]
job to your own business that's passive
okay thank you
[Music]
and now for a very exciting question
yeah Kabir man yeah can we get a
microphone up here thank you I'm looking
forward to hearing this gear yeah yeah
yeah which okay exciting quiz show on me
now yeah yeah hi Gary hey brother
I've been following you ever since 2010
Thank You varying both crush it and the
Thank You economy and it's really
changed everything I've done thank you
I published a book this year in doing
the content marketing ever since with
the guild marketing perspective I want
to show it to you later because I've try
to give you some attention in the book
even though it's on strength training
thank you my question for for today is
you've been talking a bit about
meditation
yes mental practice as being the next
big thing is call it that yes but I kind
of feel like it seems that you're a bit
afraid yes of doing it yourself I am for
what and why because my head is perfect
and I don't want to [ __ ] with it I'm
being serious
I'm being dead serious i I I could be
completely out of my mind but I am so
happy always that the thought that
meditation may do something and open up
some tunnel in my brain that takes when
you are 100 percent happy the [ __ ] would
you [ __ ] with that with but but as you
said it's good to grow but why not grow
even more your niceness you're right
what I'm scared is I genuinely think
it's a hundred and unlike business a
hundred percent of something doesn't
have a hundred and one but what if it's
80 that's a great question but in a
world where my intuition has been
everything for my entire life and my
entire intuition is like [ __ ] you I'm
gonna listen to me I'm gonna listen to
me
that's why that being said as you may
know cuz you've been paying attention
I didn't meditate twice now once in a
company I'm telling you I'm telling you
my truth I mean this is you know I
invested in a company called
enscape it has a studio in New York and
an app and then I did a podcast where
Dan Harris made me meditate on the show
it didn't go well I tried to shut off
but I couldn't I am making some jokes I
on a very serious kick I'm not super
duper scared of it there's a lot of
truth in what I just said but I'm not
against that I've already done twice I
could see myself meditating in the
future I genuinely think I'm meditating
in real time always I really mean it
I'm I'm pulling so I'm you know some of
you that are meeting me right now I'm a
real enigma I'm pulling in a lot of
contradictions I'm carrying a lot of
conflicting thoughts you know I
desperately care about you so much that
I'm reading every one of your comments
yet I actually don't give a [ __ ] about
what you're saying right like I'm doing
a lot of weird [ __ ] I feel like it's
creating that balance and I think when I
audit the market of what meditation
could do it lets people close out the
noise that's bringing them into
negativity reset refresh whatever maybe
but you're absolutely right on the
record in the same way that health
fitness became an incredible industry
over the last 30 40 years I believe that
mental Fitness meditation is going to be
quadrillion trillion billion trillion
dollar industry apps and studios and the
t-shirt brand and the headband and food
that enables better meditation and every
Kaka manian thing that every [ __ ]
entrepreneur comes up with meditation is
going to be one of the massive
commercial plays and then people that
have been in it for a long time in the
Far East and India are gonna be super
pissed because it got commercialized and
and and that's fine because more people
I'm excited to watch it because I think
a lot of people are gonna be helped
because we're just starting to have the
right conversation with each other
around mental illness and for some of us
like myself and others who've been
around people they love so much that
habit and you didn't know it for all
those years you thought it was a bad
attitude or a bad personality I'm
excited that we're gonna start putting
this in the right place in our culture
over the next 50 years and I think a lot
of people are gonna be helped also
because you've been talking a bit about
Silicon Valley also with the problems
with suicide and so on yeah in that
sense it and and to be honest with you
it's more entrepreneurship than Silicon
Valley but the biggest fear I have right
now with entrepreneurship is it's such a
personal loss guys there's a very big
difference between your business failing
and everybody watching it and you
getting fired from a job and if you
don't have the make up to being an
entrepreneur in dealing with that and
you were meant to having a job but
you're doing entrepreneurship cuz it's
cool right now you were gonna struggle
and I'm scared because I get the emails
every day I'm not guessing I'm not
predicting
I get 15 or 20 emails a week that allude
to suicide that tell me that a video
they saw huh months have you got an
email about people emailing Union saying
they were gonna commit suicide Thursday
but they saw a video that's right now
whether they're telling the truth or not
even if one in the thousands of emails
that him and I've got even if one of
them is telling the truth think about
what that feels like
we have to have straightforward
conversations no fourth-place trophies
you got to tell people the truth because
we're playing fake and then when real
[ __ ] happens
people are not equipped to deal
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
kisum yeah so where can we get a
microphone over here thank you thank you
and thank you for allowing me to add in
the question last moment it's a good
it's a good one so I'm the head of sales
at an old family company here in Denmark
old French did Mobile's one more time
I'm the head of sales yes family company
here in Denmark for three generations
we've been selling mobiles to the world
art basically art yes
okay not knock phones but pieces of art
hanging from the ceiling amazing and for
many years our soul customers have been
brigand mortise shops
yes see where I'm going with this
because now we have more customers who
we just set up their own online shop or
even start dealing via Amazon so now my
wholesalers are calling me up saying
that guy's selling into my market you
got to stop him this one is dumping the
prices stop them and legally I can't and
I'm not even sure I want to but I want
to ensure the coexistence of the to the
online shop and the brick and mortar
shell won't happen your you don't have
enough leverage to make him coexist yeah
I was hoping you might provide me one
tip you know you're away I could support
my old and faithful customers some of
them don't even have email by telling
them to get [ __ ] email I'm trying to
help you yeah I know because if you hold
on even 1% you're gonna lose and I can
see you have good intent tell me I
always [ __ ] we want to support our old
customers and we don't even have our own
online shop because this old family
company didn't want to compete with our
own customers I understand but I guess
I'm realizing that we need to there's a
very good reason
third generation companies go out of
business they hold the past on a higher
pedestal than the current you've got the
answers
listen I'm empathetic
you cut into 1/3 generate you not being
a family member in a third-generation
family business that has had success for
a hundred [ __ ] years
the problem is tough [ __ ] I'll tell them
you got it you know what you can do
something you can do is create a
workshop for all your old school
customers and bring in speakers that are
talking but you you're gonna have to
educate them that's you doing the noble
thing to help them but you can only do
so much but you're gonna have to educate
them and you're gonna have to start
sending signals that you're not gonna
protect them cuz they're playing defense
and think you will and the quicker you
don't play fourth place trophies we have
to trade on merit it's too bad but I
want to remind you that those shop
owners who are about to go out of
business they put somebody else out of
business why are we protecting the
current establishment they put the
people that used to sell art outside out
of business right like anybody who's
winning now had means they took it from
somebody else
people like we've got to protect
supermarkets why why do you think
they're called Super Markets cuz there
used to be markets and then they came
along and made them super and put the
other [ __ ] out of business right and
one day somebody's gonna say we've got
to keep Amazon alive that will happen
and to that person because I'll put it
on film right now
[ __ ] Amazon they had their time and now
it's time for Amazon
[Music]
now isn't it amazing that you came to
elevate maybe we will save a 100 year
old company just because you came here
today now to another question that day
your answer might help that he can
become 100 year company
Thomas ending where are you yeah Micra
oh yeah
thank you yeah really snappy auntie
first of all I run a small company true
persons we do a lot of content creating
I've been for the past year working with
a Danish athlete creating his content
he's a race car driver driving lamang
and stuff like that nice we're doing it
for free for him for a whole year now
and it's about time that start happen
yep
what is your ask him for money yeah and
I know that but my thought is should I
be very honest with him and ask him how
much do you earn I'm thinking about can
I can I get 5 or 10% of what you earn
anything I think in mind what you're not
gonna get 5 to 10 percent of what he
never knows that's why I'm a sure you
don't know so let's start over how how
much do you want I want to make a living
respect off of one [ __ ] guy no
because actually I work full-time or
more than full-time at my day job
understand I work like 30 35 hours in my
own company yeah
like almost no sleep and do you have do
you have any sense of what other people
are charging personal brands for content
no how much output are you giving him
I'm giving him almost all of his output
like what is it we've done 10 episodes
of on YouTube with like 10 minutes of
content like good I think it's good
quality so life let's assume it is the
habit Instagram all of his posts almost
how many like 5 a week 5 a week okay and
what else Facebook
the real old school PR like press
releases and stuff like that why are you
doing that because some of his in
Denmark we still read the papers and
stern I understand yeah everybody
everyone still reads the paper but the
papers are also online now so but when
you say press release you're writing a
press release or you're updating his
fans on what he's doing in written form
on Facebook both okay um what else like
I don't know do you engage do you guys
reply on his behalf on Twitter yeah not
on Twitter but on Facebook and Instagram
yes okay and emails and how many hours
are you guys putting in a month I don't
know maybe 30 40 hours and you and hit
your partner or just you over all the
hours or over hours like 40 or yep
so you know I think you know 1500 to
$5,000 a month is what you need to be
thinking about and then one more thing
you talked about the DM guys on
Instagram I actually did that yesterday
but it didn't work out how many times
did you do it just once and the guy's
name was Gary Vee yeah Gary Vee got
4,000 DM gesture I know I know
Justin so yeah but but but I'm glad you
brought it up because I want people to
hear us cuz we brought it up earlier
yeah you just got to keep d-roc emailed
me four times
to offer me to make a free video imagine
if he stopped at three that's the answer
to that question thank you you're
welcome
[Applause]
[Music]
now we need to hear from the hungry e
mr. signed e who wants to get hungry
again
did you my I didn't picture you as the
hungry e bro can we get a mic runner
like can we get a microphone thank you
take it away yeah how are you hi I'm
Evan pleasure so I came to Denmark five
years ago was almost nothing and I got
to work really hard I got to work really
hard just night jobs and so on then I
start volunteering a lot and kind of
after five years I made it so to say in
in my own terms and now I I find myself
not working anymore from 2:00 to 7:00 in
the night and I'm a bit concerned that
is this it like how can i push to go
forward are you are you worried that
your content and you're trying to get
the spark yes maybe you need to do
something else maybe your content in
what got you here this Wine Library I
built one of the largest liquor wine
stores in America and I did it and I was
like wait a minute the liquor laws are
bad this doesn't feel like it's it I
made it you know I did I started a
YouTube show maybe you made it thank God
in in what you I don't know what you do
maybe you need to do something
completely different and have the thrill
that I always have which is the climb is
much more fun than the stuff that's what
it's that great guy in the back the
good-looking guy with the beard I want
him to love the process not the idea of
the Mexico Beach maybe you're like me
and you love the process so much that
now that the process is not fun even
though the money's there even the
opportunities there you're missing the
spark the climb you know why I love
coming to Southeast Asia or Nora
I wish none of you knew who I was that's
the climb people think it's the other
way I don't want anybody know who I am
that's actually probably my biggest fear
is the game of like getting known you
know I plan on getting to all 7.3
billion of you and then when that's done
it's gonna be like [ __ ] do I have to go
to Mars or you know like you know so I
think that I have a feeling it might
just be that you're looking for a new
process and a new start from the bottom
to build up how can I know what to
choose next just pick something it's a
really interesting question I really
believe that like there's I don't know
you write but there's things that are on
your mind I would start with interests
outside of work like if I would start
something like if you're into video
games
I think eSports is about to be one of
the biggest industries in our society
over the next thirty years maybe you
don't know anything about eSports but
you like video games here's the chance
to start I was looking into document
yeah so now from 7:00 p.m. to 2:00 in
the morning for next four months you
learn everything about eSports and then
you decide what you want to make I think
you want the process which is incredible
because it's gonna lead to a lot of
success which is why you've probably
figured out how to win in five years
because you love the process so you were
willing to eat [ __ ] and work at night
and be patient and that's why you got
somewhere now you got somewhere and
you're like wait a minute
[ __ ] you're calibrating you're young you
need to go out and do other new
processes if you've got complete
flexibility I would do it around other
things you like music sports beer like I
don't know what your interests are
outside of it but you start there
because that's a double I mean Vayner
sports me and AJ are building this
sports agency it's a real fun thing like
we're gonna kill everybody it's gonna be
a huge company and it's fun to talk
about football like we know about trades
before they come out in public you know
we like it so I think if you can do it
surround something you like I would go
and look and discover the business
behind the things that you're interested
in
[Music]
yes Mason hmm can't get a mic wanna
thank you
Mason Mason Mason yeah how are you I'm
really well you I never thought I'd be
nervous talking to a guy but I just want
to thank the two things yeah
one of the things you changed my life
and two years ago one year one and a
half year ago I was just sitting at home
doing videos professional videos now
thought that's gonna change my life I'm
an artist first of all I learned to be a
media company first you taught me that
and I had so many videos like
professional videos and had a team
making those videos and did to do [ __ ]
for me so I just started seeing you
listen to what you had to say and I was
like [ __ ] it I just used my phone
started doing just started filming you
know and just like with the first video
after I saw you just got with like
700,000 views the first first video like
four days after I saw you if we four
days after I just made another video the
same amount of views like I got it on my
platform of Facebook here so change like
my if you see everything and I'm just
listen to you every day you know I don't
know where to start
sorry I never I'm a speaker I don't know
who yeah so what I'm trying to say is
first of all I mean I know you like
these you start with immigrants I'm a
refugee I came to Denmark so I know the
hustle I came with nothing I think
Denmark is the greatest country of all
time it's just like the opportunity we
have here is just like amazing I'm
living the American dream in Denmark
[Applause]
[Music]
so so when I started doing those videos
on Facebook just like changed everything
and then then it just started like
giving me opportunities not just starts
to realize that actually I'm doing a
living I'm living just by branding
personal branding and Danish on social
media and it just gave me like jobs
after jobs I don't even know what my
title is people ask me what are you
doing I'm gonna actually know what to
say because I'm just saying I'm living
my dream I don't know why but just
because I have this attention on
Facebook just give me like so many
options so many opportunities I'm
crippled by opportunities just like you
say you know how so that's amazing so
thank you for that I know you live like
you're running a marathon and it's your
legacy and I respect that I love that
for I love you for that
so first of all thank you for that this
sir yeah thank you the second thing is
just like just to let you know how much
of an impact you have on me because like
when everything starts to get crazy like
I have like this this year like one year
after I started doing those video I have
like at some stage called blaming
sarahindenmark is just like a huge stage
I have it like in this month it's almost
sold out 600 seats just because I'm
using your tactics on Facebook it's
crazy
thank you for that so the thing number
two thing I want to thank you for is
just like because just to let you know
how much of impact you are I have like
this dream I want to buy this at this
car Mercedes and that's yeah just like
my dream car
I just drove it because now I'm
fortunate I can afford it I just drove
it for half an hour and all I was
hearing those half an hour was your
voice is what the [ __ ] are you doing
[ __ ] so so I was just like I couldn't
do it so I'm still driving around a
shitty ass car because I'm pursuing my
dream man when you have that mindset you
become more likely to buy Mercedes the
company than that [ __ ] car
thank you
[Music]
so my question is now I'm just like I'm
still new I'm still a baby in this like
I'm still so new but I speak English and
I speak Arabic love it
so I started like at the YouTube huge
upside yes I realized that so I started
like I made a video one video on
Facebook in Arabic and just it got like
40,000 views I was like holy [ __ ] what's
happening and I love Denmark but we only
we are only 5 million here and I know if
I put the energy that I'm doing right
now in Danish because that's not a big
of a market and that has like this dream
of being the you know so let me show you
something real quick I know you've seen
this this is something I'm about to
double down on I speak English I fully
understand Russian but I'm at a practice
of speaking it so I'm basically one
language I understand - but we're
transcribing all my videos into every
language so you could do them in three
different languages but be smart with
the technology that we have now and as
you keep building up fame if you make a
video right now and saying I'm looking
for interns to translate my content from
English to all languages like you know
whether it's English or Mandarin or
Arabic or whatever you decide to be the
pillar to your point Dana just smaller
you're better off translating it into
Danish and things that I can written
word but the answer to your question is
don't overthink this one just gonna I
was like just pick one I'm gonna save
you time no more wasting time on things
that don't matter
99% of things don't matter technology is
here you will be able to translate every
one of your videos into any language you
want and over-index and Portuguese in
Brazil and Mandarin in China so don't
over debate which language you want I
would keep if I were you I'd be making
all three in Arabic Danish and English
just to keep testing seeing see what
happens you learn right don't worry
about 40,000 views versus a hundred
fifty thousand views cuz you're learning
it's not about that one thing it's about
buying Mercedes not driving the Mercedes
got it so that's what I would do
thank you so much
[Music]
I wish for all of you
the feeling that that kind of exchange
feels like I wish for all of you that
all right now Kevin yeah can we get a
mic one over here over here yeah you can
do some stretching while you wait Garry
meditating hallo Gary how are you I'm
fine you amazing perfect I'm like if we
go back some years cookie paste dragon
was like really the [ __ ] what was cookie
based tracking online marketing yeah but
now we're like more into the people
paste tracking and I think it's more
important and like it you can do more
with it what do you think about the
whole Google and only Google based
tracking versus people base tracking
from Facebook and Instagram and so on
you mean you know intent based word
versus what we're doing behaviorally yes
I think they both matter you think that
both matter sure I think like if
somebody sir so let me tell you another
tactic that maybe somebody wants to try
as you can tell when you do the tactics
good things happen there's an ad product
on YouTube which allows you to run a
pre-roll video based on what people
search on Google so I can run ads on
people who search you know motivational
speakers but even though they're
watching a skiing video I can put my
pre-roll video on them because I
understand the intent based data the
creative has to be great my first three
seconds on the pre-roll has to be great
cuz none of us want it but intent based
marketing is very powerful and extremely
good for sales Facebook is much better
for branding high-impact he's not he's
making videos he's not getting jobs
because he says and click this and then
on the landing page at night he's
getting because he's building a brand
coming to him the halo effect that's
much better
but marketing and sales both matter and
if you're good at both you've really got
the game and so I just think both matter
quite a bit thank you you're welcome now
for a really personal one battle
where's bad teams bingo can we get a mic
run to battle that's right yeah right
next to you
super hello Gary
how are you I'm good and my question is
how do you deal with people who don't
and I believe in your mission or
understanding and especially when those
people are your friends and your family
I look I like it I like it a lot
actually to be honest with you because
and I really do I prefer it I even think
I communicate in a certain way to make
people confused so that more people
don't believe in me I like it that they
like I think it's incredible I think
it's the most fulfilling thing in the
world to achieve something and look at
one of your friends and say I told you
so [ __ ] like you know I look I said
it earlier and I know I look this is a
tough question for me and let me tell
you why through DNA through circumstance
through parenting I actually am not
kidding I prefer it other of my dearest
friends my sister
for example she does not prefer it you
know but what I can tell you is at the
end of the day when you're 94 yeah
actually I got attacked can I recommend
something go spend one day volunteering
at a retirement home
if you want to fix this I've got a way
for you to fix it potentially and do
something very nice to the world you as
a young man go Google retirement homes I
know I don't know if that's is that a
culture here like there's
cuz I'm every cultures got go and email
every retirement home near you and ask
them if you're allowed to volunteer for
a day then go and volunteer when you're
volunteering make sure you do whatever
they tell you you need to do but every
minute you have talked because they want
to talk to you anyway what you were
gonna learn is a lot and the biggest
thing you're gonna learn is all those
friends and families opinions at the end
of day aren't gonna matter and you're
gonna have a lot of regret and the
scariest thing when you look an old
person in the eye when they know there
is no more ten years it's always about
regret it's always much more about what
they didn't do than what they did and I
don't want that for you and I think the
one thing that may set you straight is a
nice full day at a retirement home
all of you should do that it's a really
interesting thing I'm about to do an
episode with the Dirac because have been
talking a lot about it perspective you
know regret I lived my whole life
everything you've been you want to
capsulize everything a lot of this is
about regret it's the one that you can't
fix at the end and so many of you right
now are living your lives based on what
your parents want you to be doing and
you're gonna you're going to resent them
you're creating the culture of a bad
relationship with them not a good one
you're just putting a bandaid on it I'm
letting it go to the masses so when do
we have hands yeah do we want to pick
one yourself
this time yeah that kid in the corner
actually ironically in the same area I
noticed him earlier so let's draw I
think hey brother hi Gary I want to ask
about what show meaning on blockchain
I think blockchain is the technology
right now that has the most potential to
disrupt society I think people are
grossly under estimating what it means
what it's doing blockchain is creating
infrastructure around trust and trust
between all of us with each other with
nobody in between not central banks not
leasing companies not even government's
I think that it has the potential to
create the global next war because it's
so big what do you think my personal
opinion I really like I'm really bad at
listening to myself while I talk so I
stopped accidentally but I like it a lot
I want to it I mean I think it's a
really interesting new architecture I
guess you could say because it's almost
hundred percent
I mean it's decentralized so there's no
one controlling it and I mean it has a
lot of power I just think I don't know
explaining do you think that China and
America and Russia are gonna let it see
its power I mean I don't think they like
it but since it's decentralized I don't
think there's any way to stop it
sure there is mmm can you give an
example sure they can start suppressing
their citizens yeah okay I don't have a
counter answer to that I don't I don't
either by the way I'm just super I don't
the reason I'm exchanging right now is I
don't people were like Bitcoin guys get
educated on what's actually happening
here like pay attention to the
conversation we just had a minute ago
this is a big deal
I don't know I don't know either you got
something on it blockchain is a protocol
I guess it's an infrastructure I don't
know what that what people are calling
it what is it a protocol it's
essentially of baking network which
every piece of intimate information is
stored in blocks and its publicly
viewable so everyone can see it and
verify that everything is true and and
there's mining technology that creates
them yeah that's the ecosystem the
ecosystem is around miners which are
machines it's it's basically you and I
you will sell me your home in 11 years
and our transaction will happen on the
blockchain nobody else which means all
those fees in between you and me so you
know I don't talk about a lot because as
you could tell I don't even know that
every terminology I'm been paying
attention I bought Bitcoin four years
ago I'm I'm watching but [ __ ] it's heady
it's you know I'm laughing because I was
like Bitcoin I'm like oh do you know
what a theory I'm is do you know what
blockchain is like this is very intense
what you know I think it's youth naivete
that says Russia and China and America
can't do anything about it
it is literally literally literally the
thing that can undermine that yeah
they're not that interested in that of
course not yeah cool thank you
speaking of Technology the tech guys
want you to put it a little closer to
model is that thank you
next question do we want to pick one
yourself
yeah how about Judy all the way in the
corner there and then I'm gonna go to
that we're gonna go to that dude next
and I don't want to pick a lady God
should I see you hey Gary my name is mos
my question concerns
business-to-business sell yes what is
your biggest advice with in
business-to-business sell is it customer
relationships or is it challenge to
Facebook social mean so usually the
answer is hold the mic what is your you
know your talk so I love that you
started with customer retention right
mmm I think everybody's hunting they
forget about farming usually the best
way to build a real big business is to
keep the ones you got as much as getting
new ones right hmm so Honda behind it
what's that to hunt or behind it
that's right well to me it's more about
hunting and farming being hunted as your
competitors at least how I think about
it to me it's farming you got something
you got a seed and now you cultivate it
right you don't want customers for one
year you want them for 11 it's a far
more interesting model my question to
you is what's the biggest vulnerability
in your opinion the hunting or the
farming right now in your company
retention or acquisition it's actually
acquisition great it's probably because
you're spending marketing money in dumb
places probably yeah good so don't
that's a good no wise thank you but like
you know we you know obviously I think
it's Facebook and LinkedIn
I think it's influencers I think it's
long-form content I think it's starting
a podcast for the industry I think it's
white papers I think it's videos short
and long form on Facebook I think all
that stuff works okay as you know when
you look under the hood most b2b
companies are spending 5% of their money
on all the things I just said and 95 on
Google spamming on LinkedIn
b2b magazines Direct Mail trade shows
sponsoring dumb [ __ ] eiseley was a good
advice earlier about the targeting the
co-workers and in the companies that you
want to target yeah and then make
creative because I want to make sure
everybody's listening it's not just
targeting you got to make the video say
does your head of finance understand or
you know you got to set that person up
because that employee may be a secretary
a salesman a you know an IT department
person they're not gonna just they're
not it's not for them so the way to make
it for them is asking them does your CEO
know to meet you know you're looking for
someone who cares about the business
since I go [ __ ] you know so be smart the
content is the variable of success I got
in front of you here today
now the talk was gonna be the variable
of what happens with us going forward
the content is the variable of success
he looked at I you know I smiled I
almost stopped him buddy was on a roll
he said I owe it to you your tactics his
execution he heard me
he understood Facebook video Facebook
videos more upside than YouTube it's
easier to break out the end like he
understood he watched carefully I got to
him but it was his charisma and
capability to story tell that has made
him successful there's plenty of people
that have listened to me and made a
video and nobody [ __ ] watched it cool
thank you
[Applause]
yep so thank you so much for for your
time of course and I'm a guy who's like
I like systems and practical stuff I'm
sorry yes I'm a big fan of like
practical things and so like recipes in
terms of how to do things okay and what
I want to know is what would you do to
grow an influencer organically unlike
social media Facebook YouTube these
platforms organically yeah on Instagram
I would use 15 hashtags as the first
comment after the post after I spent 40
to 60 hours understanding which hashtags
were the perfect balance between a lot
of people use them but they're not one
of the top 25 because I'll never
penetrate it because I'm too small got
it number two I would DM as many
influencers in the same 50 mile radius
or interests if the person can travel as
me and I would DM them to figure out
what I could do for them in return for
them collaborating with me and taking a
picture on their account and tagging me
to siphon their audience to me yeah
perfect got it cool what about Facebook
and YouTube YouTube I'm in a punt
because the organic nature of YouTube is
so predicated on the creative and
collaborating is far more intense than
taking a photo so I'm just gonna punt it
Facebook I would email people that have
media pages around the cat what what
does the influencer do what genre so
intrapreneurship entrepreneurship I
would go to every entrepreneur media
site on Facebook and email them and ask
them if they wanted any of the content
that this person was producing for free
to post on their page perfect now now
everything I just told you on the DM and
the emailing you're gonna get it one out
of every 50 people responding so you
need to hit 37,000 perfect okay I got
one less thing punted I do it's an
American term when in when in football
when you play if you don't get a first
down you punt to the other team and they
start over I'm just saying take YouTube
and [ __ ] it when I'm not
when on Instagram and and Facebook first
and then leverage that to build on
YouTube the stakes are just it's just
too hard
supply and demand and tactics on YouTube
to break through there's a lot of titles
and thumbnails even I haven't really
fully penetrated there are people that
are better at it I don't like to give
advice when I don't know everything and
so and I also know the other two right
now are under priced perfect thank you
welcome my friends I know a lot of you
don't know me and you've been we've been
hanging for a little while that was a
very tactical question others have been
so [ __ ] philosophical I just need
people understand we'll go right to this
lady over here the philosophical
strategy stuff is way more important
like a lot of you like that last
question like a lot of you liked it I
know your personalities but I'm telling
you that's the commodity there's 8,000
answers to that question on Google if
you search how to grow organically on
Instagram finding somebody that
communicates to you that breaks through
your mindset and creates a new strategy
that's the ROI and I may be that person
today and I may not but continue to seek
somebody to get you in the right place
if you can't get there yourself hi hi
Gary
my name is Fabiola and there is a lot of
men fans of you and there is also a lot
of women and I'm one of them thank you
and maybe people look at you and think
Gary we he's so confident and but what
about me I'm I'm not that confident
right so what is your biggest secret to
become yeah be more fearless and take
chances to step up where maybe people
are hiding yep so you know how earlier I
said I don't know how to teach you
empathy because I don't I used to answer
this question the same way and then
the cool thing about life is you get
wiser you watch and something breaks
through and I actually have an answer
for this and I'm I don't say it a lot
then I'm super pumped you asked me so
thank you you need to do two things you
need to start hanging out with people
that are overly confident you need to
look around your world friends of
friends go to meetups look in your
office remember a friend from college or
high school you need to become friends
with more people that are confident and
tomorrow you have to cut out one of your
friends who's pessimistic and negative
out of your life not totally but you
don't need to talk to her or him three
times a day maybe three times a month
this is an energy game so that's
something that when you are thinking
about it
you are still afraid of I'm afraid of
snakes I'm not afraid of anything
emotionally other than death even even
that I'm starting to finally get there
in the last two or three years nothing
emotional nothing emotional I'm afraid
of the health of my family the help of
your family that's it the only thing I
ever like you know is thinking that my
kids and wife are flying to Florida the
other name what if that plane like
that's tough hmm but only that extreme
not I don't think anybody could do
anything to me which puts me way ahead
of everybody I do not believe that
anybody can do anything to me and that
is more about me taking responsibility
more than anything else once you
eliminate that hmm once you don't think
anybody else has any effect on you once
I have I have something else which is
the cousin to that that makes me strong
I don't expect anything from anybody and
I've never done anything ever in my life
with an expectation of something in
return that's ahead of 99% of pee
but when you started and there must be
something you were scared of where you
just was oh my god I cannot handle this
people know the only the only thing that
was different when I started
professionally than everything I just
told you is I was fearful that people
would feel that my dad handed it to me
and I would never get the credit I
deserved but that was a 17 year old
mindset that evolved pretty quickly you
know I took care of that in the first 24
months by growing the business from 3 to
20 million like that ok yeah so thank
you so much Gary listen listen for all
of you to new friends that are confident
and positive cut out one person that's
negative including if that's your sister
I'm being [ __ ] serious already did it
good I mean it it's not you cut him out
you never talk to them but you have to
reframe the conversation because
negative energy misery loves company is
the currency that nobody is talking
about that's how you get more confident
you know around people who want you to
win and they make you um I'm doing it
for you for my hardest core fans I'm the
one doing it for you I'm so confident
that you you know why why I have made
more people do things because we create
such an intimate relationship in the way
that I'm producing content and
interacting with you that there's almost
a weird friendship even though I don't
know you yet so that if you fail you
feel like you could be like Gary you
could like blame me and I love it
I'll take every blame ok I just have the
last question because how are you
actually communicate to influence like
you as a I really want you I can't and
can be honest you say I should be honest
I really want you on my podcast fabulous
yeah because I want the greatest leaders
and the biggest vision of your podcast
ok that's a deal
you know I saw lymangood email me at
Gary at vaynermedia yeah say I was the
woman that waited to the bitter end to
ask to be on the podcast I will get
Tyler involved T Schmidt at vaynermedia
you can watch the videos of this if you
forget but I'm Gary at vaynermedia and
I'll do your podcast and then you'll go
to every other leader and because I did
your show they'll do it too and because
you asked something good will happen I
love you thank you thank you
hi Gary
how are you I'm your favorite fan you
know why
well actually favorite public it's
because I don't know you the only reason
I'm here today yes actually very funny
cuz you probably DM Tony Robbins yes and
I saw you on a video with Tony Robbins
and I'm a Tony Robbins girl and that's
why I'm here I just II I'm Tony Robbins
seven years ago Tony Robbins emailed me
and asked me to speak at his conference
because I create content so people ask
me the other way around and I should ask
Tony how he did so I do that episode
with Tony and that's how you first
became aware and that's how it started
yes exactly good because the name of my
company doesn't matter but it it has
something with elevating people and the
reason I'm here and I've been sucking
out everything you said because I've
been writing every word that comes out
of your mind because I believe we learn
from people with experience I talked
about it with Casper a lot of people
think that knowledge is power and I
think that application of knowledge is
power and learning from somebody who
takes all that knowledge and puts it
into applies into in this work I can
learn something from you so of you I
started my company two days ago
doesn't matter what I sell what I do but
I'm in a place where everybody here
would love to be because I have a market
and I want to be very smart with how I
come out with my product I've been
giving value to people for the last
three and a half years without asking
for anything so I have a market how by
showing up giving talks
doing a voluntary work for a nun not
profitable organization and 1.2 million
people know who I am today and they
basically say what is it you do what is
it you sell we can buy how do you
quantify that number Rotary
International
Rotary International I don't know well
Rodri is a nonprofit organization doing
good in the world and I promote
fundraising for for doing good in the
world doesn't matter I have a product at
the moment which is a service and I am
standing in a place where two days ago I
started my company and I haven't really
come out with the product because I want
to ask the very crucial question fast
first or second safe should I let
somebody else go out with my idea and
try it and learn from all the mistakes
or should I be the first one
now I'm an entrepreneur in my in my in
my core because I started two
organizations and I know I'm good at it
and I put 18 hours a day and I don't see
my children I know I can do it but now
it's money until now I've been doing it
for fun I've been doing it voluntarily
but now it's like putting my own money
out there should I let somebody else do
it first and then learn from all the
mistakes or should they just go
headfirst and learn from my own mistakes
but then somebody else will learn from
my mistakes and go faster
why can't you learn from your mistakes
first then go faster - well because
until now I wasn't attached I always
started two organizations no real quick
that not the personal mental question
yeah you said that you're gonna go for
you know you get you painted a picture
and you said and what I'm worried about
or debating is if I go first
somebody's gonna see the mistakes I make
they'll go second faster and I
understand you know this you know
everybody the early bird gets the worm
the second Mouse gets the cheese right I
understand the theory it's very basic
because my mommy's then let me let me
tell you something you need to reconcile
no purebred entrepreneur ever thought
about going second so you have to wrap
your head around that
when it wasn't money you were deploying
entrepreneurial tendencies you weren't
being an entrepreneur so you've got to
wrap your head around that the fact that
you're even debating it actually I'm not
it's something that came up since I met
you because you have applied all those
things that you're teaching us on your
own business and you got better and
you're very good at saying okay 17 years
ago I wasn't so good at it I wish I
could have done it better and today
people are doing it better because of
your experience and so you should just
do it just do it because the only thing
I can't see the I don't know we're not
spending enough time here unless you're
worried about the failure I'm not other
other people's opinions absolutely not
then you've created a fake narrative
Amazon and Google and me and others we
went first
we failed plenty other people here they
went first so forget about I don't want
to put myself at them people that have
won here have gone first failed fixed it
and gone faster before any but you've
created a fake narrative that somebody's
gonna be second first of all nobody
gives a [ __ ] about you or me sure so
nobody's really watching so let's start
with that that should make it much
easier for you to go first but second of
all the person that goes first and fails
nine out of ten times is the one that
adjusts and goes fast again this second
Mouse is not as cool as you think thank
you
[Music]
yeah we would love to take more
questions but unfortunately you're also
moving forward and there we have a lot
scheduled for the rest of you but I
would like to ask a question regarding
the whole mass in here because elevate
for several years has been a community a
community of people coming back every
year
I can recognize many of you sitting here
but we have also many new people here so
what is your best best advice to Casper
and everybody else about how to create
an amazing community an amazing
community for the organization's benefit
I assume which is what you would be
wrong also for each other many of the
people here it won't be a big together
and have learned each other so it's
simple you can create a framework that
allows them to communicate with each
other
mm-hmm whether that's through email or a
Facebook group or an app that you build
you'll decide how to do it but the
biggest sorrow why for people here is
for the people that are the least
extroverts and won't go up to somebody
right now and say hello and Exchange who
are you is the ability to interact with
each other um there's not the reason I
ever go to anything is for the follow-up
email I don't go to many conferences but
I'll go to a lot of dinners where I
don't know anybody else that'll be
twelve people from different backgrounds
the 99% reason is because once I make
context the email that comes the next
night that puts everybody on the same
thread I can pick the three people that
I want to email out of that and say hey
let's follow up on that or let's do
business together or I can help you or
I've got an employee that's ready to
move on who's great she wants to be an
entrepreneurial person not an agency you
should hire her the great thing that you
could do for everybody here and this
community is build a framework that
allows them and pushes them and helps
them and Caudill said that woman almost
didn't ask if we didn't hold on a
hundredth of a second longer she almost
didn't ask for the things she wanted to
ask and since she did it's going to
change at some level her business and
her life she we all were just here she
was this close to not asking
she didn't ask luckily we punched around
for a couple more seconds and she
[ __ ] finally got that and she went
there right there's a lot of people here
who are literally right now sitting next
to a person that can change the course
of their lives and career and they're
not gonna say anything to each other
because that's not the way they interact
in life and if you can do anything that
gets them to do that then you're doing
them a great service
listen we're talking about two cents
four cents six cents let's go we got to
go no no no no let me close it Bab and
you what you kind of missed you missed
it there yeah yeah
Blagh bab and missed it but we loved him
a little bit more than the rock slightly
behind her and but anyway nonetheless
would love to get your thoughts would
love to get your two cents on this key
note we'd love to get your favorite
quote because the team is starting to
suck at these Instagram quotes so now I
need my community what was your favorite
quote actually that fit [ __ ] two cents
what was your favorite quote from this
keynote
[Music]